protip don't over expose your footage
you can do noise removal on dark footage
but there's nothing you can do to
recover blowing out overexposed footage
protip if it's cold outside bring toe
warmers for your friends dummy
protip movement can imply a feeling or
gradually reveal information if you do
your best move as smoothly as possible
and shoot a little wide you can usually
stabilize your video in post-production
and it can look really good protip when
you're shooting stunts zoom out a little
wider than you think you have to that
way you're going to get all the action
in the frame no matter what protip shots
that have seen like sentences in a
paragraph make sure you eat shots do
something if a shot holds for longer
than it takes to verbally describe the
shot you should probably make it shorter
protip before you call your edit final
make sure someone else watches it to
critique it that way you're gonna have
the best results
protip camera technology is always
getting better you'll probably go
through lots of cameras in your lifetime
however a good lens is good for ever
your image is only as good as the glass
that's passing through protip always
make backups of your footage you know
you're gonna regret not having in the
future it's not gonna be money trust me
it's could be your footage protip it's
easier and cheaper to get good sound
than it is good video because of this
many people consider it an afterthought
don't a film with good video and bad
audio is much worse than a film with
good audio and bad video
protip if you suck at sound mixing put a
hard limiter on your audio what that
does is it takes all the clipping levels
and brings them back into range so the
speaker's don't blow out do that
protip weed you script out loud to
somebody before you commit to shooting
it you'll discover all your funky
sounding lines that way
protip don't be afraid to zoom in mixing
focal lengths will make things look much
more cinematic protip everybody loves
snacks before you worry about paying
people or all that stuff just get some
good snacks it makes everyone happy
you're on set and it tastes great
protip a good video is 10% idea in 90%
execution a simple idea done well and
make for a really good video if you
really want to hone your skills don't
whip in yet you really want to hone your
skills practice doing one or two minute
pieces protip there's no shame in using
tape make sure you bring some table on
set you have any problems or things got
look works great protip ash Alice can be
just as useful as the storyboard and
take far less time to make fro tip we
have more Pro tips on twitter follow us
protip when you're shooting stunts shoot
a little wider than you think in case
you missed some of the action